alors que faire si on veut réduire
l'utilisation des herbicides et qu'on ne
veut pas non plus nuire aux fragiles
équilibres qui règne dans le sol une
partie de la solution se trouve
peut-être dans l'histoire qui suit
nous sommes à princeville à la ferme de
michel thibodeau
4 cei est beau c'est une super
protection contre le gel je pense
qu'avec la vie
meilleure protection aujourd'hui deux
agronomes qui suivent les champs de ce
producteur ont fait le déplacement car
michel thibodeau se livre à une
expérience plutôt inusité on va le voir
ça dans le château fait que en ce 10
juin le seigle atteint les épaules et
malgré les apparences ceci est un
championnat comme la ferme de grandes
cultures est en régie biologique
impossible pour michel thibodeau
d'utiliser des herbicides pour se
débarrasser des mauvaises herbes il
aurait pu faire comme ses confrères
producteurs bio et sa clique entre
l'iran
moi j'aimais passe à sarcler donne donc
quand tu aimes pas quelque chose devient
jamais bon donc j'évite me laissa clair
dans l'entrepôt puis passer à d'autres
choses il a donc adopté la technique du
soya dans du seigle rouler le segway est
aplati à 3,4 endroit là il va être là
dessus je veux être brisée à peu près à
toutes les sauces là puis une fois qui
est bien bien à placer au sol là bas ils
vont mourir le il va sécher puis le voir
faire un pays de deux parutions peut
dire l'odeur paille de seigle l'idée de
rouler une culture n'est pas nouvelle
depuis des décennies des producteurs bio
aux états unis se servent de rouleaux
pour détruire entièrement des cultures
de couverture aux états une union plus
long de 16 ans où ils pouvaient rouler
le 5-4 à ce sommet un seuil haut à en
étant à certains de leurs rangs des
matins maturité là
pour éviter que le seigle ne repose
après avoir été roulé il faut attendre
sa pleine floraison ce qui arrive vers
la mi juin à cette date il est déjà très
tard au québec pour semer du soya et
espérer avoir une bonne récolte
chez michel thibodeau le rouleau conçu
par l'agriculteur est fabriqué sur
mesure permet donc d'éviter le seuil a
semé un mois plus tôt entre les rangs de
seigle
la particularité c'est que c'est tout
des rouleaux de 20 po ce temps qui reste
un espace pour le soya qui est pas
rouler ici à l'automne dernier ce que
c'était ton radis moutarde
ou la technique a débuté l'automne
précédent
l'agriculteur a semé de rang deux
siècles qui ont survécu à l'hiver et
deux rangs d'une culture de couverture
ici c'était de la moutarde et dur a dit
qu'ils sont morts à la saison froide
c'est dans cet espace libre qu'il a
implanté son soya début mai le but de
mettre 2,5 c'est vraiment de faire un
pays qui va empêcher le plus possible la
croissance des mauvaises heures
l'agronome julian wilkinson mène un
projet de recherche pour mesurer
l'impact de cette approche novatrice ce
que ça fait le sexe c'est qu'il ya un
petit peu moins de lumière qui va
pénétrer dans le couvert végétal donc le
soya il va chercher la lumière qu'on
remarque sur les plans c'est que la tige
est peut-être un petit peu étiolé le par
rapport à soyaux qui serait semé pendant
un couvert végétal
michel thibodeau confine cette technique
depuis 2018 le rendement de son soya est
équivalent au soya sarcler dans sa
région le producteur sauve aussi
plusieurs passages de machinerie et donc
de l'argent selon ses calculs les
économies atteignent en moyenne 250 $
l'hectare sans compter les avantages
pour la vie du sol
tu affrontes raflant tous que d'un seul
change stable avec un métabolisme de sol
qui est beaucoup plus rapide piqué
capable de prendre du carbone les
transformer pendant matière sèche la
transformer en humain stable et il est
convaincu qu'il y encore beaucoup de
place à l'amélioration
la technique conventionnelle avec du
roundup ready là ça fait
30 ans qu'on fait seul avec du roundup
ready il ya des producteurs qu'il
améliore encore le même
mec si on avait mis autant d'efforts
pour mettre au point des techniques
comme ça puis se faisait trente ans
qu'on les pratiquer
on serait probablement ben d'ailleurs
qu'on est nul l'eau gelée fait avec du
ceg mais un jour des producteurs vont
l'essayer avec d'autres types de plantes
puis peut-être les résultats vont être
encore meilleure arme en est on va
arriver avec des choix de plantes puis
des ingénieurs une machine qui vont
faire en sorte qu'on vaut vraiment bien
maîtrisé la technique avec un impact à
long terme un impact sur le sol qui sera
meilleur
[Musique]
m